2 le jardin
étymologiquement c'est un enclos
destinés à protéger le meilleur le
jardin c'est aussi un espace pour semer
et pour s'aimer le jardinier courbet qui
regardent de la terre qui la travaillent
il va donner il va aussi recevoir et il
console l'humanité d'une partie de ces
mots je suis ce qu'on appelle un
entrepreneur social
ça veut dire que j'ai été formé en
sociologie et au travail social mais
j'ai jamais véritablement fait ce
travail là j'ai toujours monter des
entreprises des entreprises dites
solidaires
ça fait pas de vous pour autant un chef
d'entreprise puisque les chefs
d'entreprise se disent il est bizarre ce
type aux mêmes petites canailles
agriculteurs dit c'est quand même un
drôle de zulu stick jardiner au même
titre que les sociologues et les
travailleurs sociaux 10 il fait plus
partie tout à fait du truc puisqu'il est
devenu entrepreneur mais je voulais
simplement faire passer déjà le message
à tous ceux qui s'intéressent à ces
entreprises sociales et solidaires que
l'entrepreneuriat social on prend
vraiment beaucoup de plaisir et je suis
très heureux de pouvoir faire ce métier
tout a commencé il ya très longtemps
mais d'abord en montant ce qu'on appelle
un jardin de cocagne un jardin de
cocagne c'est une exploitation
maraîchère en agriculture biologique qui
fait travailler des publics en
difficulté de toute nature recrutés sur
un territoire et qui ont un job très
particulier ils vont produire des
paniers de légumes biologiques qu'ils
vont distribuer à des adhérents
consommateurs des gens comme vous et moi
qui savent tout de suite et qui
comprennent tout de suite ce que veut
dire bio locale et solidaire
tout ça a commencé dans une région un
peu oublié des dieux dont je suis
originaire qui s'appelle la franche
comté
elle est connue pour son côté elle son
côté très rural elle est aussi connue
pour son industrie automobile mais moi
ce que j'en retiens surtout c'est
qu'elle est aussi rempli d'utopistes qui
m'ont rempli mon enfance et mon
adolescence
coudon fourier proudhon considérant le
doubs courbet et là vous avez une vue de
comme quoi il y avait déjà du lien entre
les utopistes puisque c'est courbet qui
peuplent coudon tout ça ça aurait pu
rester une petite initiative provinciale
mais à un moment donné je me suis
retrouvé un espèce de nomades jardinier
qui devaient répondre à des demandes qui
venaient de partout parce qu'il ya eu
une couverture presse assez rôle
relativement important de ce premier
jardin que cai
donc je me suis vraiment planté si je
puis m'exprimer ainsi pour mon retour à
la terre puisque je me suis retrouvé à
passer beaucoup plus de temps dans les
tgv à l'aider d'état de porteurs de
projets mais c'était magnifique de faire
toutes ces rencontres de d'agriculteurs
cave envie de changer de vie de pouvoirs
publics qui avaient envie d'orienter
différemment les choses et qui avait
envie de monter des entreprises qui
puisse correspondre aux gens en
difficulté sur leur territoire toute une
série de gens qui avaient envie qu'ils
m'ont passionné que j'ai accompagné et
tout ça j'ai pas le temps d'en faire
toute l'histoire mais ça donne
aujourd'hui 132 jardins de cocagne en
activité est pratiquement 25 mille
panier qui sont livrés chaque semaine à
des adhérents consommateurs et plus de
5000 personnes qui ont retrouvé une
activité qui travaillent dans ces
jardins de cocagne 4510 en insertion et
puis 800 qui sont des personnels dits
d'encadrement axe
tu es de gérer un jardin de cocagne
c'est une drôle d'aventuré c'est une
drôle d'aventuré parce que c'est un
projet qui à la fois économique qui à la
fois écologique et qui à la fois
sociales une fois qu'on a dit ça on a
cité les trois grandes soeurs ennemies
du développement durable qui se
détestent mais qu'il faut faire
cohabiter donc vu au foie prendre à
devenir ce qu'on appelle un gestionnaire
de tension et vous serez toujours
frustré en interne et en externe
frustré par vos collaborateurs qui se
dit me nous emmerdent toujours à vouloir
changer des choses et puis de vouloir et
dans la stabilité
et puis des partenaires extérieurs qui
savent absolument pas dans quelle case
ou venger mais voilà pourquoi on a fait
ce travail autour de cette devenir des
gestionnaires de tension mais parce
qu'on pense que l'humanité le mérite
parce que l'humanité dans une période
inédite aujourd'hui notre humanité est
traversé par une économie cannibales et
financiarisée qui ne sait plus créer de
richesses sont créées autant de pauvreté
dans un effet centrifugeuses si vous
rajoutez à ça des problèmes écologiques
majeurs dont je vous ferai grâce et dont
on va parler beaucoup dans quelques
semaines avec des problèmes énergétiques
des problèmes démographiques vous
obtenez un cocktail invraisemblable qui
fait qu'à un moment donné on peut
considérer qu effectivement on est dans
une période inédite que l'humanité n'a
jamais rencontré et en plus de tout ça
après 25 ans d'histoire ces jardins de
cocagne eux aussi rencontre toute une
série de difficultés et sont en pleine
mutation et cette mutation
elle est liée à des baisses
d'intervention publique ou là on
s'aperçoit qu'effectivement les pouvoirs
publics malgré toute la bonne volonté
qu'ils n'ont plus les moyens d'endiguer
toutes ses vagues de pauvreté
d'exclusion
il ya des nouvelles montées de chômage
et d'exclusion en permanence on a il n'y
a pas que les chiffres du chômage qui
compte en la matière
et cerise sur le gâteau puisqu'on vend
des paniers de légumes
v'là t'y pas que tout le monde se met à
vendre des paniers de légumes la grande
distribution les le secteur agricole etc
et c'est donc une hausse de l'activité
concurrentielle comme relativement
importante donc il faut se bouger dans
ces moments là il ya une humanité qui va
pas puis desjardins qui à un moment
donné était une très belle histoire mais
qu'il faut quand même durée et en
l'occurrence on a essayé de réagir par
un triptyque stratégiques autour pour
penser un autre avenir
d'abord tout près d'ici en créant ce
qu'on appelle la maison coq à la maison
que qu'elle vous initier tous invités il
y en a certains des gens qui sont déjà
venus
ça va être un jardin ça va être un lieu
de s'était déjà un jardin il ya déjà
trente personnes qui travaillent déjà
des adhérents consommateurs
il ya des clients dans la salle
d'ailleurs et puis un moment donné c'est
aussi un lieu de recherche et
développement et un lieu de formation ça
va être la maison mère de tous cocagne
est effectivement de partager avec tous
nos partenaires
la deuxième chose ça va être de se
bouger un petit peu pour aller chercher
d'autres modes de financement donc on a
créé le groupe cocagne qui permet
d'aller lever des investisseurs et
trouver des dons et en l'occurrence
aujourd'hui s'il ya plus d'argent chez
les pouvoirs publics
il n'a encore un petit peu dans les
entreprises il y en a comme un petit peu
chez les citoyens
vous avez d'ailleurs que les français
sont des gros seins mais beaucoup des
parm de deux côtés donc on voudrait les
alléger un tout petit peu
en ce qui concerne la deuxième la
troisième chose c'est qu'effectivement
il faut un rapprochement très important
avec le monde de l'entreprise
ce monde de l'entreprise dans ce moment
je parlais de période inédite d'humanité
qui on compte une période inédite
il faut inventer des alliances inédites
et ses alliances inédites que nous
invitons à faire c'est à dire
modestement ces petites structures
d'insertion solidaire qui s'appelle
desjardins cocagne c'est un mixte
d'intelligence territoriale qui
rapproche les pouvoirs publics qui
rapproche les citoyens et qui rapproche
les entreprises il n'y a pas tant
d'initiatives qui sont capables de le
faire parce que les pouvoirs publics les
citoyens les entreprises c'est comme mes
trois soeurs ennemies tout à l'heure on
peut pas dire que les pouvoirs publics
ont une vision idyllique de l'entreprise
qui le rendent bien en même temps que
les citoyens peuvent audi toute une
série de mauvaises appréciations des
deux autres mais pour autant c'est la
nature du projet le sens sur le
territoire qui va donner la possibilité
à ces gens qui naturellement n'aurait
pas fait d'alliances d'aller et de le
faire mais pour faire des alliances
encore faut-il bien se connaître se
reconnaître s'apprécier casser les
représentations dégradée qu'on a des uns
des autres et donc ce que l'on invite à
faire et là je veux vous montrer
quelques images quelques slides à dessus
de grandes entreprises qui ont sauté le
pas qui ont décidé de se rapprocher de
cocagne pour essayer de voir comment on
pouvait faire quelque chose ensemble
donc dans un premier temps avant de
faire des grandes théories avant de
faire des grandes alliances avant de
faire de la co construction c'est-à-dire
montée des futurs entreprise ensemble
demain il faut tout simplement se mettre
au travail
et là vous avez un cabinet de
consultants spécialisé dans la fusion
acquisitions internationales en train de
j'ai des pierres et de faire un
aménagement paysager
vous avez là une grande entreprise on
manie faut pas les citer donc une grande
entreprise qui fabrique de l'électricité
en france et qui est en train de planter
des arbres dans un des vergers qu'on est
en train de mettre en place
vous avez ici une grande entreprise du
luxe en france qui vient qui vient
apprendre des cadres sup à prendre avec
des femmes en insertion dans le sud de
l'essonne à confectionner des bouquets
bio locale et solidaire
c'est ce qu'on a fait ce projet qui
s'appelle fleurs de cocagne là aussi
j'ai pas le droit de cité les nommer il
y en a dans la salle on a aussi des
relations très aboutie avec des
entreprises des grandes entreprises qui
vont nous aider à concevoir un
restaurant ce dans cette maison cocagne
un restaurant il s'agit pas de
réinventer n'importe quoi mais quelque
chose d'un concept qui ressemble à
cocagne toujours avec ce côté social
toujours avec ce côté écologique
toujours avec ce côté économique
moi ce que je voulais aussi vous attirer
votre attention c'est sur cette photo ça
c'est une équipe dite en insertion sur
un jardin cette équipe qui vient de
recevoir une grande entreprise elle les
femmes et les hommes qui la constituent
ce de fleurs de cocagne raconte toujours
la même chose le lendemain
enfin on a pu rencontrer on a eu une
mise en scène possible avec des grands
cadres d'entreprises qui ne nous ont pas
pris pour des moins que rien qui nous
ont apprécié à qui on a même appris à
confectionner des bouquets avec qui on a
créer véritablement des liens
les gens de la grande entreprise ne
raconterons plus de bêtises sur tous ces
gens en insertion qui serait selon
certains un ramassis de feignants qui
veulent demander que des minima sociaux
vous êtes un feignant quand vous venez à
7 heures du matin courbéteux faire un
gros travail dans une dans un jardin
coquen absolument pas et donc à un
moment donné ces gens là la suprême
difficultés qu'ils rencontrent
et qu'à un moment donné la pauvreté la
misère vous emmène dans un truc
incroyable c'est que vous finissez par
vous détestez vous même et il faut
réapprendre à s'aimer et quand je dirais
apprendre à s'aimer dans un jardin c'est
pas qu'un jeu de mots c'est aussi un
moment donné on ne peut rien envisagé
dans sa vie si à un moment donné on ne
peut pas retrouver un minimum d'estimé
de soi donc toutes ces entreprises qui
viennent j'aurais pu en citer encore
encore d'autre part dont je vais trop
vite
des exemples certaines viennent
aujourd'hui parce que nous connaissent
bien
chaque chez des futurs collaborateurs je
pense à des hypermarchés
je pense à d'autres avec qui on a
atteint des degrés très important avec
l'entreprise que j'appelle de
co-construction c'est à dire qu'on n'est
pas sur un coup on n'est pas dans un one
shot on est en train d'en prendre pour
15 ans et 20 ans ensemble et je pense à
un grand groupe avec lequel nous montons
des nouveaux jardins de cocagne sur des
délaissés qui sont délaissés de terrain
en bordure d'autoroute dans différents
endroits de france et qui se décline
différemment quand c'est en région
centre ce sera un jardin de cocagne
concédant le sud de la france on est en
train de planter des oliveraies et c'est
donc vous voyez bien tout bénéfice pour
l'entreprise et tout le bénéfice pour
cocagne et en l'occurrence je voulais
simplement dire pour conclure que sur ce
plateau de saclay si cocagne est venu
c'est toujours pour continuer son métier
continuer son métier d'aller au plus
près des grands exclus de leur retrouver
une fonction de leur retrouver un
travail de les accompagner
on peut pas le faire seul il faut le
faire avec ses alliances et je voulais
simplement dire que ce plateau qui est
temps de saclay qui est en train de
rassembler on en a vu un boom joli
fleuron aujourd'hui toutes ces grandes
entreprises qui vont qui peuvent laisser
penser à un moment donné que l'avenir ne
sera que technologique
je suis simplement modestement venu vous
dire l'avenir ne sera pas que
technologique
il y aura besoin de solidarité il y aura
besoin de bienveillance et y aura besoin
de lien alors comme o dia cocagne
ensemble q
yvon la solidarité